Here We Go From timcast.com Russia
activates world's most powerful nuke the
Satan II missile is one thousand times
stronger than the bombs dropped on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki and could destroy
the UK in six minutes now I want to slow
down there a minute and the most
powerful nuke there's a variety of
reasons why it's described that way but
I think it's fair to say that there is a
diminishing return on the power of the
nuclear weapons we currently have and
it's because uh you know I love Moore's
logic you guys are familiar with Moore's
Law right that you know every two years
the processing power doubles or whatever
and then eventually got to the point
where they were like no it's officially
going to stop but then they did
multi-core processors so they figured
out a way that make the law technically
keep going that's the thing with nuclear
weapons it got to the point where these
very very powerful nukes we had sarbama
and then eventually someone was like I
got an idea let's just put 12 nukes in
one rocket and now we've got something
substantially more powerful and it's
like okay well there you go so for this
one it is powerful
but we've got nukes that are 1 000 to 1
250 times more powerful than the bombs
that were dropped on Hiroshima and
Nagasaki the Satan II missile while
massive and extremely powerful standing
at a hundred feet high nearly
Unstoppable is one of I would say in my
opinion not that I'm a combat expert
anything one of the most powerful uh
nuclear weapons it's being deployed into
combat Duty and I already know a lot of
people uh we've got one Super Chat from
Tim Jake saying that it's standard
replacement of obsolete equipment and
things like that some people are saying
oh don't be so dramatic here's why I
think this is there's a reason we bring
this up
I think I have the story right here from
the AP Ukrainian drones strike deep in
Russian territory Moscow says while a
barrage in Kiev kills too
Vladimir Putin said they would not use
nukes unless they were facing an
existential threat
and now we are escalating to the point
Insider reported just the other day two
days ago the ruble is failing and now
more Russians are cutting back on buying
basic basic Goods like food and
toothpaste you've got this several now
military strikes in Russia there was a
military incursion into Russia from the
Ukrainian side and now Russia is
deploying whether it's a standard
replacement or the activation of their
most powerful weapon
we are escalating to that point
the most important thing to understand
with this
this is reality there is no point where
someone comes and grabs you by the
shoulders and screams the nukes have
been launched it's happening now
almost everything that happens is
gradually and then suddenly which means
when we look back on History a hundred
years from now when they look back
they're not going to teach young people
assuming there are people I don't know
they're not going to teach them that you
know in today's class we're going to
read about the two-year for the next two
years of school we're going to be
reading about the day-to-day
um you know monotony of the the
political uh class and and politics in
these countries no they're going to say
the date was November you know 17th 2020
with Donald Trump now contesting the
election this led to the July 40 you
know the the July uh 15th whatever and
then we saw one year later the
deployment of the Satan II missile of
course two years after that it was
deployed and New York City was heavily
damaged that's how quickly it goes when
you're when you're going through history
for us sitting here right now understand
this could be something it could be
nothing I don't know but this is how it
will always be another grain of sand is
added to the Heap I have to say when
Russia activates one of the most
powerful nuclear weapons that we've been
fearing for some time they've expressed
the the the intent to use nuclear
weapons in the event they face an
existential threat and now we are
entering into war on Russian territory
story and a threat to their existence
we're a lot closer than we have been in
a very very long time to the use of
nuclear weapons now I am not saying
they're going to Nuke New York or
anything like that but New York did put
out a PSA what was it like two years ago
about what to do in the event of a
nuclear strike more importantly keep
your eyes open for an escalation of this
war Tucker Carlson warned that in order
to stop Trump they will declare hot war
with Russia officially I think the first
thing we'll see is likely going to be
tactical nuclear weapons on in the
combat field nuclear artillery I do not
think we're going to see the use of the
Satan II missile on a civilian Target
like a city that serves little purpose
other than to try and end the war
outright I don't think it would be
effective uh uh this early on in the
conflict but I'm curious what you guys
think I think that the the the fact that
they've activated it
um has changed the game because there's
the United States is going to have some
kind of reaction right the the Soviet
Union is or not so Russia is not going
to be able to uh
to put a a weapon like that into play
and expect the United States to not do
anything so I imagine that there's going
to be some kind of escalation and again
it's not going to be like the us is
going to like just uh start deploying
nuclear weapons but I and I don't know
what it would be but I don't think this
is going to go unanswered and it just
goes back to what I've been saying or
we've all kind of been agreeing on is is
I don't see the exit I don't see the
off-ramp there's a lot of things that
are happening and there has been nothing
at all since Russia invaded that has
been even that has moved the needle
towards a ceasefire de-escalation uh
ending combat activities nothing in two
years now or so or year and a half so I
still don't see the off ramp turning on
nukes is what you know everyone's afraid
of because Russia's nuclear armed I I
don't see how it gets fixed there was uh
an attempt at a peace talk between I
think zelinski and Putin even early on
and then uh Boris Johnson went down
there and ended the peace talks abruptly
and I think Victoria Newland might have
been involved so essentially Britain and
in the United States were like no no no
no peace is not a good idea we need this
War I don't know uh do you remember that
yeah that was this is something that
people mention a lot um I don't have
data to pull up right now on me and it's
anecdotal so I can't prove that that
happened but I've heard it a lot so
there is that would at least you know
that would at least explain that there
are some people want that zelinski
doesn't want the War I mean I don't
think zelinski wants to fight I don't
think he wants the people to die I don't
think zilinski's come right out and said
that his goal is to totally just take
back Crimea like zielinski said that
yeah so he's not so it's not like he's
not looking for any kind of funny
escalation or whatever well but it's not
zelinski it's NATO that's what I'm
saying it's it's Boris Johnson and
Victoria Newland pushing pushing zlinski
and probably will kill him if he doesn't
play it I don't think I don't think
they're pushing him I think they're
playing him like a marionette
man
uh it's
I I don't know I don't know it's it's
rough that uh that they've completely
devastated the Eastern Don bass turned
it into mud and all those people have
died I don't think anybody wants and
This Is War I mean Russia is involved in
this they're the ones who initiated it I
I find it absolutely hilarious there's
this really great post that said you
know ways you know that you're a
bootlegger for the Empire and it's that
you completely ignore all the things the
United States and NATO did to escalate
tensions which resulted in this war and
if and if you bring it up if someone
brings it up you get offended and I'm
like right
this politics is not happening in a
vacuum Russia didn't one day be like you
know Vladimir Putin didn't twirl his
mustache and say I'm going to be evil
today no it's a it's a it's a fight over
special interests resources they need
the seaport they want Sebastopol they
want to fortify the roads down into
Crimea through Eastern donbass the East
one East 97 and East 105 those two
freeways I can if they can fortify that
and Russia can take that and solidify
their base in Crimea uh Sebastopol is
the city they'll start pumping out goods
and services into the Mediterranean Sea
but that will create make turkey a
vulnerability for NATO because turkey
he's in NATO Ian I I hope that you are
ready to die so that NATO can defend
Ukraine's
milk water water Port yeah it's more
that they don't want Russia to have it
because then they think Russia and
Turkey will buddy up and the turkey will
leave NATO and then they will NATO will
fall apart if Turkey leaves NATO I mean
the I I I want to strongly push back on
the idea that without turkey NATO falls
apart well it's already kind of trash
that is complete just that idea is
completely not true I mean it's a
nuclear power that controls the Russia's
access to the Mediterranean I think if
it's it's not just Russia's they control
the Bosphorus which is all of the black
seeds the Mediterranean it's which is I
don't know mostly Russian it's Ukrainian
also Ukrainian so they could shut off
Ukraine in access to or some of it
anyway what's so wild about is the
hypocrisy because Boone's been saying
what for 15 plus years do not put NATO
troops on my border or else and I'm like
how did we feel about it when the Cubans
or excuse me when the Russian Soviet
Union was putting missiles in Cuba like
it's a no-go and if they were oh sorry
go ahead I just want to say there is
turkey does not have new are you sure
I'm looking at it right now I looked it
up I Googled it so and that's part of
why we get so many countries in NATO is
NATO exists partially to uh limit
proliferation of nuclear weapons that's
why you get countries to join NATO we
offer you protection we have nuclear
weapons don't develop nuclear weapons of
your own that was the whole point of the
United States being like kind of the big
dog in NATO and stuff is to prevent
nuclear proliferation sorry for cutting
off no you're good thank you and you
know speaking of nukes you know
something we should entertain is the
possibility of an EMP bomb if people
aren't familiar there are devices
allegedly that and I don't doubt it uh
that can take down entire power grids
and they're I'm pretty sure that's we
know they exist right like a nuclear
detonation releases an EMP intentionally
right I'm pretty sure we've isolated and
we can generate an EMP and and like a
neutron bomb right and the last several
uh Department of Homeland Security uh
heads have said that you know a grid
down scenario is one of their their
number one concern because there's so
many different things that could do it
it could be a solar flare it could be
bad actors it could be a hack job and
there's all the so if you look into this
there's been so many different
electrical grids or the substations
around the United States that have like
had been mysteriously hacked and
infiltrated by various hackers it's like
who's doing that and why Jimmy have you
ever read the book one minute after Yes
actually yeah yeah I got it on
audiobooks about after the nuclear about
an EMP so they've been shooting EMP off
over over the US let it off for about
100 miles up or whatever the EMP takes
out the entire grid and it's based I
think in North Carolina I believe so
correct I think it's Asheville is the
the area but it talks about you know the
the things that could happen and stuff
like that Newt Gingrich actually wrote
the forward to one of the uh editions
I'm not sure which one so but go ahead
I'm sorry I was gonna say hey if you
guys want a conspiracy in between now
and the next year I'm convinced that
there's gonna be some sort of event
they're going to come at us with some
sort of curveball like everyone they're
putting out covid mandates into the
media now and I'm like I think that
there's a sizable uh portion of the
populace that will not comply I don't
know what the percentage is even if it's
just one out of three that's too many
and I don't think that they're gonna put
this time I'm expecting a curveball so
what better like if you study history in
like Sun Tzu and the Art of War so
instead of nuking us or doing a a bomb
off the coast to flood us why not just
turn off our lights let us destroy each
other from within most people are not
prepared uh but you know how most people
would die if the guard goes down
waterborne illness most people do not
have sterile water we take it for
granted you turn on the faucet and
you're fine I got I gotta I gotta stop
you right there
you said how most people would die that
might not all right most might not be
the worst significant number millions of
people would die from from from
infection of going to the bathroom
because they they their stomachs can't
handle you know that raw water that's
going to turn once the water treatment
facilities go down so never mind
percentages but like when the water
treatment plants go down there's no
water at all right so in places like New
York and Chicago you turn the faucet on
and nothing comes out and game over
because how many what two days without
water three days and you're and you're
just incapacity I would say by day two
people are drinking each other's blood
yeah I I am not exaggerating there was a
martyr maid has this post about what
Civil War really is and what people
don't understand and I'm and it really
is something we bring up all the time
that people just it's like
there's nothing you can do about the
fact that people live in movie reality
that they don't think about what how the
world actually works and so they imagine
people marching with uniforms
martyr maiden and a couple other people
had tweeted Civil War is like
everything's you know you're you're uh
you know the conflict is happening you
you see it in the news you go to bed you
go to bed and you don't wake up because
a warring faction and three in the
morning sneaks in your house kills you
in your sleep takes your stuff or you
wake up and your neighbor's house is on
fire and you see him his corpse lying on
the on the sidewalk because a warring
faction came in and he was a target for
some reason these kinds of things are
are likely to happen first in a
breakdown so outside of the concept of
Civil War right like let's let's not be
too cliche with Tim cast here
let's say EMP bomb nuclear strike
Cyber attack
you know Rachel Maddow said they're
going to shut off our electricity they
could with a Cyber attack
yeah if our grid goes down I think we've
I I if if Communications go down
that's it the fabric of the United
States evaporates overnight and you ever
play the video game Fallout 3 yes I love
Fallout 3 it's the best video game ever
made one of them and uh The Enclave let
me let me give everybody a general
understanding I I assume most of you
know Fallout 3 some of you might not in
the Fallout series uh in like what 2077
China invades Alaska because there's
dwindling fossil fuels and they need
access to new resources War breaks out
nukes go flying
Planet gets bombarded and most people
die a large portion of people in the U.S
go into underground vaults to try and
survive in Fallout 3
uh I forgot where I was going with this
what it would be like you know after the
The Fallout from it I mean just the
complete societal collapse and
everything else yeah I forgot the point
I was gonna make because I started
explaining the basic story it was about
like the enclave and then you got it
there it is Communications
so uh in Fallout 3 the bad guys are the
enclave
they're the US government
but they are completely powerless and
they have no control over what is the
United States so in in the Fallout world
there's the new California Republic
which is the remnants of California are
rebuilding and forming their own
government but The Enclave is actually
the descendants of U.S military U.S
government that went into Mount weather
and other bunkers when the bombs fell
when they emerged they had no way to
control what was left the Wasteland the
yeah the apocalyptia so in the event
Communications go down how does the
military communicate they've got
contingencies I'm sure and they have
protocol for what happens if like the
communications go down but what about
local police federal law enforcement it
is there there's going to be a Decay a
breakdown as as uh as you get out
further and further outside of the
government of actual Communications so
what happens then if the grid goes down
and Communications are blocked for some
reason we lose the internet we lose
electricity we're turning our radios on
trying to figure out what's going on
and then
bad people go on the radio and say this
is Lieutenant so and so I'm in charge of
this area and it's a random guy
then he comes in and says we're
organizing what if it's a militia and
they feel Justified and say to
themselves if we don't get a hold of
this it's going to get bad I'm taking
charge put out a radio call put on their
militia uniforms look like military show
up with guns they're not bad guys but
they're not the government and now
you've got conflicted factions
determining trying to figure out who's
in charge and who isn't it would happen
it'd be a power vacuum somebody would
try to take care of us you need like if
you're in a city you're doomed okay so
that I mean that we can take the you you
can take like the idea of survival off
the table you're dead you're you are a
Walking Corpse so take if you live I'm
not kidding you're going to be someone's
lunch yeah you're you're totally doomed
you have like if you're on Manhattan
you're doomed you're never going to get
off the island if you're on Long Island
you're doomed you're never getting off
there if you're in southern Connecticut
you're gonna die if you're in Jersey
you're gonna die there's like well to be
fair pointing out like if five percent
live I'm generally right it's kind of my
point you know right but but you know
for for Jersey so long as down in the
peninsula right if you're on the islands
Manhattan Long Island the New Jersey
Peninsula you're done yeah when when we
were in we were in New Jersey when the
coveted lockdown started and there were
rumors going around they were going to
shut down the bridge
Connecticut already had checkpoints with
New York because New Yorkers were
fleeing to Connecticut so when we heard
that they were like that's what everyone
was afraid of they're like hey if they
lock that down you're stuck you ain't
going anywhere you're on a peninsula so
we're like we should probably leave now
and so we packed up and we we came down
to uh where we are now earlier than we
intended and that was just the lockdown
scare but uh to your point in terms of
the the land areas that have have access
to the larger Mass United States have a
substantially substantially higher
chance of survival Manhattan Island good
luck you're dead
yeah the police blocked the one road out
your best bet is to know your sheriffs
and your local law enforcement or at
least be familiar with them so that way
you have an idea of who might have
authority in your area but that ain't
gonna work if you're in a city with
police because police are not the same
as sheriffs like they have a different
uh different Outlook and stuff and
Authority is meaningless
yeah in uh have you but that's where the
authority will be will be drawn from
have you guys seen uh The Last of Us the
TV show uh yeah actually I just started
uh I just finished up that first season
recently yeah very interesting what
people need to understand there is no
good or evil in a conflict there is
survival and what's what's going to
happen is
dude
you're walking down the street
let's say it's a month two months after
after the the grid gets knocked out and
there's chaos happening and there's
conflict
there's people starting to rebuild
Communications the US government is
still asserting its Authority but as you
move further west and things get further
and further and spread out
Communications break down distance
between cities increases East Coast may
be stable West Coast will be
increasingly unstable
so let's say it's several months later
and you're walking down a road and
you've got your you know rifle on your
back and your water and then you come
across you see in the distance there's
some kind of settlement and you're like
well let's go see you who's there and
then all of a sudden there's a bang and
you're dead in fact you're dead before
you even hear the sound the people who
live in that settlement aren't going to
be like oh hey look a fellow walking
towards us with a gun about video games
and this like fantasy of survival
apocalypse genre and games like dude you
get hit once you're dead everybody dies
but it's not just that's no fun it's
that depending on the level of conflict
the assumption that you can walk up to
any kind of settlement and they're going
to be like howdy stranger I couldn't
help but notice your arm there you want
to come hang out they're going to be
they're either going to jump out from
like they're going to come out from
fortified positions you can't see them
pointing weapons at you telling you to
get on the ground you're going to lose
your weapons you're going to lose
everything and if you're lucky they'll
turn you away and take all your stuff
right a Loot drop right but and maybe
they won't kill you or maybe they just
do it and think if you find out if you
want if this person wants revenge if
this person tells someone where we are
we're done don't know don't care this
idea that you know everyone's going to
be super nice to each other and rolling
us together crazy crazy talk no
strangers will be looked at us and I
mean you wouldn't you wouldn't know who
you could trust and and by the way like
is is you know like the boom shot you're
dead uh if you if you get hit in the arm
or leg or wherever you're just wounded
you're gonna get infected and die like a
week later uh in a very terrible
terrible way most likely you're gonna
bleed out because most people don't have
tourniquets right like most people don't
have First Aid on them well like you get
into a gunfight your friend get shot he
dies because he bleeds out because you
didn't put a tourniquet in your car and
I guarantee you don't have one in your
car but you have shoelaces a lot of
people don't know how to use a
tournament right exactly let me let me
let me tell you guys something really
simple a shoelace and a pen have a nice
day Google it figure it out but I've got
dudes are dead but this is the look look
I would I'd be willing to place a large
wager that the majority of people listen
to this show have a substantially higher
survival rate than the average person
and it's you have to be paying attention
what's going on in the world to watch a
show like this yo come on every you
could be listening to Barstool you could
be talking about the World Series of
Poker you'd be talking about football or
the ball game the drafts or
whatever and and hey man do your thing
do you think I got no beef enjoy your
life be happy live laugh love whatever
but my but when it comes to what's
happening in the world maybe it all
settles down maybe nothing bad happens
you know uh there's there's a big good
cause for optimism in uh Trump's current
polling numbers economic numbers things
are looking fairly positive that you
know I genuinely believe that while
Trump is a is far from a perfect
individual
the Trump path slowly winds thing things
down in fact uh I don't know about
conflict the United States but
internationally World War III nuclear
bombs it's the only one that actually
might have an off ramp there is nothing
coming out of the democratic party or
the Democratic establishment or the
Republican establishment that in any way
indicates that there is an off ramp for
the conflict in Ukraine it is oh we
gotta win and that ain't happening but
if Trump does get elected while that may
avert us being wiped out nuclear
Hellfire
civil conflict the United States is
still a large a high possibility there
is a lot of turmoil coming in the next
10 years or possible but I want to add
really really quick to everybody just as
an aside download General Survival app
like it's not a proper noun it's a it's
a it's not a proper Google search go to
your Google Play Store type in Survival
app download three of them also some
cool items are CB radio shortwave radio
that you can talk into to communicate
with someone if the grid goes down you
have solar power and a life straw
LifeStraw is the name of the company but
they basically you can take Dirty River
water and drink it through this life
right through right now everybody
uv5r is a is a two-way radio yeah you've
I think it's uh VHS definitely UHS and
they're like 25 bucks and they are the
most common radio going around they're
super easy to use
how fast I also want to say download
download the app called picture this are
you guys familiar with that one let's
see up we're like a picture of it and it
tells you what it is basically picture
this yep picture this can take a picture
uh it takes picture of I believe it's
plants yeah I think so that reminds me
yeah tells you if you can eat them yep
buy hard copy books too just in case
there's a situation with the grid a
survival book as well as a first aid
book and there are also books which just
made me think of it is that depending
what region you live in for example I'm
in the I'm in Arizona I'm in the
southwest so I have a book that's
literally edible plants of the American
southwest and you can do it on any
region you're in because especially when
it comes to first aid and other you know
survival situations you know if the
internet's not available all you have is
a hard copy and we take that stuff for
granted exactly yep yeah you can also
download the ranger handbook which is a
the actual military ring like the US
Rangers you can download their handbook
and that's got a lot of stuff in there I
just put a link to it on my Twitter
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time